قد افاد مراسله الجزيره بان معارك تدور
بالاسلحه الثقيله بين الجيش والدعم السريع
في المنطقه الصناعيه بالعاصمه الخرطوم
وبشارع الغابه بينما حلقت الطائرات
الحربيه على امتداد اليوم في سماء العاصمه
وام درمان بالتزامن معدويه اطلاق مدافع
ويستمر اندلاع الحرائق في منشاه النفط
والغاز عقب الهجوم يوم امس على مجمع
اليرموك للصناعات الدفاعيه الجنوبيه
الخرطوم وكانت محاور القتال بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في العاصمه
شهدت معارك وصفت بانها من اعنف المعارك
منذ اندلاع القتال بين الطرفين
وفي غرب السودان قال البخاري احمد عبد
الله نائب رئيس التحالف السوداني الذي
يحكم ولا يتغرب دارفور ان عدد القتلى خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه في مدينه الجنينه بلغ
850 اضافه الى الفي جريح كما ادى القتال
الى احتراق مئات من المنازل والاسواق وكشف
البخاري انما سماها الميليشيات دمرت كل
الموارد ونهبت الاسواقها وجففت موارد
المياه مع انقطاع لشبكه الاتصالات